cos'è il tempo tutti noi sappiamo cos'è
il tempo viviamo nel tempo è un concetto
primitivo che noi tutti conosciamo
eppure è molto difficile descrivere dare
una definizione esatta del tempo questo
lo sapeva anche sant'agostino che
scriveva appunto che cos'è dunque il
tempo se nessuno me ne chiede lo so bene
ma se volessi darne spiegazione che me
ne chiede non lo so potremmo definire il
tempo come quello che ci permette di
vedere lo scorrere degli eventi dal
passato al futuro attraverso il presente
ecco c'è quindi una specie di freccia
del tempo potremmo dire una simmetria
nello scorrere del tempo in quanto nelle
tre dimensioni spaziali possiamo
tranquillamente andare avanti indietro
secondarie a destra a sinistra in alto
in basso mentre nel tempo dobbiamo per
forza andare in avanti d'altronde tutti
noi nasciamo cresciamo invecchiamo e
moriamo sempre in questa direzione e lo
sperimentiamo nella vita di tutti i
giorni
ad esempio se vediamo un filmato come
questo come per magia c'è una persona
che prende dei pezzi di banana e con un
coltello
zac zac oplà magicamente ricostruisce
una banana come era al di partenza
oppure vediamo quest altro filmato dove
ci sono delle persone esultanti che
applaudono perché vedono questa nuvola
di fumo e polvere dalla quale come per
magia nascono due grattacieli
ecco questi due filmati sono strani sono
bizzarri capiamo subito che c'è un
trucco il trucco è presto detto stiamo
vedendo il filmato al contrario indietro
nel tempo in quanto i fenomeni
macroscopici delle nostre vita
quotidiani avvengono solo in una
direzione nella direzione sono
irreversibili nel senso che vederli in
senso opposto
è strano bizzarro non succede mai ecco
che quindi questo è essenzialmente il
cuore del concetto del secondo principio
della termodinamica che dice che
l'entropia dell'universo aumenta sempre
ora è difficile spiegare cos'è il
concetto di entropia
senza voler essere perfettamente
rigorosi e l'entropia potremmo
associarla al concetto di disordine se
prendiamo ad esempio questa matrice di
tessere
blu e gialle e le mischiamo in maniera
caotica mischia molin mischiamo un certo
punto raggiungeremo una configurazione
tipo questa che c'è a destra dove le
tessere sono alla rinfusa se ora
continuiamo mischiarle mischiarle prima
o poi ci chiediamo
ritorneremo alla situazione di partenza
dove tutte le tessere blu sono a
sinistra e destra e gialle a destra
la risposta è no il tempo fluisce solo
in questa direzione verso lo
sparpagliamento verso il disordine o
meglio non è impossibile tornare alla
poi condizione di partenza è possibile
ma è semplicemente altamente improbabile
ecco questo è il concetto dell'entropia
l'aumento dell'entropia ci spiega
l'aumento del disordine 15 spiega questa
unidirezionalità della freccia del tempo
mi ricordo quando forse ero ai superiori
mi spiegarono per la prima volta cos'era
l'entropia provai a utilizzarlo come
scusa per mia mamma che si lamentava che
la mia camera la disordinata
io dicevo è non è colpa mia e l'entropia
che aumenta dell'universo però è una
scusa che non funzionava ovviamente ecco
che allora se l'entropia dell'universo è
destinata sempre a crescere allora
capiamo che alla fine la morte
dell'universo sarà per entropia cioè
sarà quella che si chiama la morte
termica dell'universo dove cioè tutta la
materia e l'energia saranno sparpagliati
in maniera omogenea per cui non ci sarà
più possibile fare nessuna
trasformazione e quindi non sarà più
possibile neanche la vita ecco ma che
cos'è allora la vita selinger premio
nobel per la fisica padre uno dei padri
della meccanica quantistica e nel suo
libro del 1944 what is life
cos'è la vita disse appunto che secondo
lui la vita si nutre di entropia
negativa cosa vuol dire che vuol dire
che un essere vivente non solo
combattere gli effetti nefasti
dell'aumento di entropia che lo
porterebbe alla morte prematura ma
addirittura fa il contrario
lavora contro l'entropia per creare
ordine per creare strutture informazioni
infatti se ci tagliamo il nostro corpo è
in grado di ripristinare la ferita e
ripristinare i tessuti
vent'anni dopo nel 64 la nasa chiese un
gruppo di ricercatori di cercare la vita
su marte o su altri pianeti
allora uno di questi james lovell hoc si
chiese cosa possiamo fare per
riconoscere la vita su un altro pianeta
una vita magari diversa dalla nostra non
basata sul carbonio
non ci aspettiamo di vedere persone con
due braccia due gambe come noi allora
qual è la risposta che diede beh per
cercare la vita dobbiamo cercare delle
isole di bassa entropia questa forse è
la definizione più generale di vita la
vita è organizzazione è informazione e
strutture complesse cioè bassa entropia
questo tuttavia non contraddice il
secondo principio della termodinamica
perché si può anche creare un'isola di
bassa entropia a patto che la
diminuzione di entropia che sia a un
certo punto in un certo istante di tempo
sia più che bilanciata dall'aumento di
entropia del mondo attorno
ecco che allora se torniamo all'esempio
che facevo prima della mia cameretta
quando ero piccolo io potrei mettermi lì
a piegare i vestiti e ordinarli
impilarli bene mentre armadio ma facendo
questo devo fare fatica ci metto del
tempo
alla fine magari sono sudato e quindi mi
raffreddò scambiando la mia calore con
l'ambiente quindi le molecole dell'area
si agitano e perché aumenta il calore e
questa agitazione e entropia e aumento
di disordine e questo aumento di
disordine si dimostra che è maggiore
dell'ordine che io ho messo nei vestiti
piegati e quindi non si può fare niente
l'entropia del diverso per forza deve
sempre aumentare e quindi anche il
concetto di riciclo delle cose che noi
usiamo in tutti i giorni è sicuramente
fondamentale però non è la risposta
ultima infatti riciclando comunque c'è
bisogno di prendere le sostanze
rimaneggiarlo e quindi si spende lavoro
fatica e alla fine comunque il bilancio
di entropia
e a nostro sfavore cioè non possiamo
combattere contro l'aumento
dell'entropia e quindi la vera risposta
per rallentare la morte del nostro
pianeta per eccessiva entropia è quella
di prima ancora di riciclare e di
consumare poco appunto però non abbiamo
ancora detto perché l'entropia aumenta
per spiegare perché l'entropia aumenta
possiamo tornare al nostro esempio
le tessere blu tutte a sinistra e gialle
tutte a destra ora vediamo un filmato
qui a sinistra dove ad ogni fotogramma
si scambiano di ordine due tessere a
caso si prendono deve essere a casa e si
scambia ecco vediamo che pian piano
aumenta il disordine ora facciamo andare
il filmato molto più veloce 32 volte più
veloce di prima e vediamo che
rapidamente si mischia e vediamo che
saliamo nella curva di destra verso una
situazione definitiva del 50 per cento
qui destra questo grafico rappresenta il
la percentuale di tessere gialle che ci
sono a sinistra alle sinistra
inizialmente tutto era blu per cui
partiamo da zero e pian piano aumento
aumenta affinché giustamente alla fine
più o meno statisticamente legge dei
grandi numeri avremo metate essere a
sinistra metà a destra 50 per cento
questo scenario finale è quello che noi
potremmo chiamare appunto la fine
dell'universo quello che prima ho
chiamato la morte termica dell'universo
dove tutto si è sparpagliato e da lì non
ci si sposta più però se guardiamo con
attenzione facciamo la lente
d'ingrandimento vediamo che in questa
regione in realtà 50 per cento solo alla
media ma realtà è un processo dinamico
l'ordine cresce e decresce attorno al 50
per cento per voi se questo fosse
l'andamento dell'entropia non di queste
piccole tessere ma dell'universo intero
e ci trovassimo ad esempio qui nel punto
di minimo vedremmo che l'entropia
aumenterebbe sia andando a destra cioè
avanti nel tempo del futuro se andando a
sinistra cioè indietro nel tempo nel
passato e quindi diremmo che non c'è un
senso unico il tempo può fruire entrambi
le direzioni non c'è freccia del tempo
ancora di più se vivessimo invece in
questo istante di tempo indicato dalla
freccia rossa cioè sull'apice allora
diremmo che non solo non c'è freccia del
tempo perché in entrambe le direzioni
passato e futuro l'entropia allo stesso
carattere ma per di più diremmo che il
secondo principio della termodinamica e
sbagliato in quanto il futuro o il
passato comunque ci porta ad una
diminuzione di entropia non un aumento
quindi capiamo che noi non stiamo
vivendo in questo scenario
stiamo piuttosto vivendo negli eventi
iniziali in un universo ancora giovane
ancora ordinato l'uomo si trova qui
infatti se noi guardiamo al futuro
vediamo un aumento di entropia
se guardiamo al passato
vediamo una diminuzione di entropia
quindi c'è una freccia del tempo il
tempo può scorrere solo una certa
direzione
e quindi la vera domanda ora è capire il
perché del punto di partenza perché
all'inizio tutto era ordinato come le
nostre tessere tute blu da una parte
tutte gialle dall'altro beh noi sappiamo
che all'inizio dell'universo c'era il
big bang e di band tutta la materia era
tutta concentrata in una piccola regione
grande come la punta del mio pollice e
quindi a temperature elevatissime a
pressioni elevatissime ora come faceva
l'universo a far stare tutta la materia
l'energia in uno spazio così piccolo
beh possiamo pensare ad una valigia se
noi vogliamo mettere un sacco di cose
dentro la nostra valigia li mettiamo
alla rinfusa non ci starà molto dentro
la valigia giusto se invece vogliamo
farci stare molti vestiti molti oggetti
cosa dobbiamo fare per prendere un po di
tempo con calma piegare il bene i
vestiti a utilizzare ogni minimo spazio
e organizzare bene il tutto
ecco per il big bang è la stessa cosa
per poter far stare tutto in uno spazio
così piccolo
l'universo doveva essere istanti
primordiali molto molto ordinato e
quindi a questo punto ci stiamo
chiedendo qual è veramente la ultima
domanda che i cosmologi ci stanno
facendo in questo momento i cosmologi
stanno cercando di capire l'origine
dell'universo perché l'universo
all'inizio era così ordinato
eccovi detto subito che la risposta non
esiste non sappiamo ancora
sono più di 50 anni che ci lavoriamo
qual è il vero motivo per cui all'inizio
tutto era così ordinato a bassa entropia
ci sono diversi scenari e vi faccio un
elenco di possibili scenari e lascio a
voi scegliere quale vi sembra secondo
voi il più ragionevole il primo scenario
è una risposta che in realtà non è una
risposta
il primo scenario dice è così e basta
bisogna accettarlo senza farsi altre
domande però capiamo bene che l'essere
umano intelligente si fa queste domande
vuole pretende una risposta vuole capire
il perché se c'è qualcosa di particolare
non di casuale
ci deve essere stato qualcosa sotto e
infatti qualcuno cioè col secondo
scenario pensa che questa sia la prova
scientifica più vera e più profonda
dell'esistenza di dio o chiamatelo come
volete di un ente superiore che ha
voluto e potuto
creare l'universo così ordinato
all'inizio e quindi da noi adesso noi
siamo 14 miliardi di anni dopo
qui a osservare quello che succede
oppure ci sono altre teorie una teoria
mi piace chiamarla la il teorema della
scimmia instancabile non so se conoscete
la sea la scimmia instancabile una
scimmia che voi mettete davanti ad una
macchina da scrivere una tastiera di un
computer e questa ovviamente schiaccerà
a caso i tasti senza saper scrivere se è
instancabile quindi avete un tempo
infinito davanti a voi e direi anche un
numero infinito di fogli a disposizione
ecco che prima o poi per caso riuscirà
addirittura a scrivere la divina
commedia
ecco applicato al big bang potremmo dire
che l'universo è così grande e ha così
tanto tempo non ha fretta l'universo che
prima o poi semplicemente mischiando a
caso quelle fluttuazioni delle tessere
che abbiamo visto prima se disporranno
per caso in maniera completamente
ordinata che il big band e da lì noi
siamo evoluti in quello che vediamo oggi
solo che questa fluttuazione che porta
per caso ad un ordine così elevato è
effettivamente improbabile ma veramente
improbabile
tanto che questa teoria oggi è
praticamente non accreditata da nessuno
scienziato è piuttosto più probabile un
secondo un altro scenario quindi il
quarto quello che si chiama il cervello
di boltzmann che è un po un paradosso e
dice piuttosto che creare il big band
che necessita di un ordine incredibile
di un di una fluttuazione molto elevata
e piu probabile piuttosto che in questo
momento nell'universo esista solo una
mente senziente e una mente che potrebbe
essere la vostra in questo momento è
tutto il resto cos'è niente una finzione
generato dal nostro subconscio esiste
solo una mente autocosciente questo
l'abbiamo già visto in molti film ad
esempio in matrix dove si dice che
quello che noi vediamo la realtà in
effetti non è vera ma è una finzione del
nostro subconscio una proiezione del
nostro cervello
ecco poi esistono altri scenari ad
esempio quello del multiverso il
multiverso è una parolaccia che vuol
dire che non c'è un universo in
contrapposizione all universo ci sono
tanti universi universi paralleli e
quindi il big bang in realtà non è
veramente l'inizio di nulla
ma è un punto all'interno di un universo
madre più grande magari dovesse già
raggiunto l'equilibrio termico dove non
c'è una freccia del tempo è
semplicemente all'interno di questi
universi paralleli si crea quello che
noi conosciamo che il big bang ci sono
diversissimi tantissimi altri scenari
che si potrebbero verificare e
potrebbero essere la vera risposta
basti pensare che recentemente sappiamo
che l'universo che noi conosciamo in
realtà è solo il 5 per cento del tutto
cioè il 90 per cento della materia e
dell'energia dell'universo in realtà è
fatto di materia oscura e di energia
oscura che ancora non conosciamo bene
come funzionino
ecco potrebbe essere che in futuro
studiando meglio l'energia oscura e la
materia oscura sia possibile dare una
definitiva spiegazione del perché
l'universo è partito dal big bang così
ordinato e quindi spiegare che cos'è
effettivamente l'entropia perché
l'entropia aumenti sempre quindi
spiegare cos'è il tempo
cos'è la freccia del tempo e in
definitiva che cos'è la vita grazie
[Applauso]